شخصيه الاسبوع بلا منازع في صباح العربيه
هو عمره في الثانيه والثمانين عاما فاجا
النجم العالمي البت شنو بالتاكيد محبيه
ومتابعيه باعلان انتظاره لطفله الرابع من
صديقته المنتجه نور الفلاح الباتشينو
مشاهدينا سيكون ابا للم
ره والثلاثين فضلا عن توام يبلغان من
العمر 22 عاما النجم العالمي البرجين كرر
مفاجاه النجم الاخر
روبرنينو الذي اعلن قبل اسابيع انجاب لطفل
بعد بلوغ سن التاسعه والسبعين
فتح باب فتح باب الشتل
الجدل ما بيني وبين عادل
من العمر وبين الرفض والقبول يبدو انهما
ليس وحيدين بين المشاهير مشاهير العالم
وفعلها بعد الستين طيب لنتعرف على البقيه
من اللي ينجبه مع الزميل يعني لميس بعد
قليل لكن خلينا نقول ترى حتى في عالمنا
العربي هناك نجوم مشاهير بعد الستين او
بعد 60 كان عندهم اطفال يعني هو مش مش اشي
مستغرب
واضح بانه ممكن
نحكي على المنطق على المنطق عشان انه
الاطفال يكون عندهم الفرصه يكبروا مع الاب
والام يعني ايضا انتم ايضا شاركونا على
هاشتاق صباح اندر سكور العربي مع راويه
وانه من غير المنطقي ان ياتي برجل بعد
الستين بعد السبعين بعد 80 بطفل في هذه في
هذا العمر المتاخر الراي لانه يحق له اذا
كان مقتدر اذا كان فاذا مقتدر حتى
انا انا برايك هذا لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات